all the way back in 1997
yours truly stevo got his first
sponsorship
by a company called xyz clothing which
was started by
danny way and the first time they flew
me out to california to shoot an
ad for the magazines i was with danny
way and a bunch of the team riders
and i wanted to prove myself to them so
when they offered me a bong hit
i ripped it and then chugged the bong
water
and that somehow won them all over what
i didn't know when i was in that living
room
was that danny way was getting ready to
not just
break the world record for the highest
air ever done
but to make it go from nine feet to
16 feet how because he built the first
mega ramp for skateboarding
he did a backside air 16 feet above the
ramp but it was overshadowed by the fact
that he jumped out of a helicopter
into that mega ramp it was the jumping
out of the helicopter that was on the
cover of transworld skateboarding
magazine and
in that same issue was my first
full-page
xyz ad where i was blowing the fireball
on my buddy ryan simonetti coming down
the handrail
so i was practically right there when
the mega ramp was born
now keep in mind when all of that went
down i had not yet even been to clown
college
i had basically accomplished nothing
and danny wade the guys from xyz
clothing were the first people to see
potential in me and then when jackass
comes out and i'm doing all this crazy
stuff
guess what danny's doing he's got a
whole new mega ramp with
two jumps one for distance one for
height he's doing front side hill flip
360s 720s 60 feet long
and then in one run he consecutively set
the record for the longest air
and the highest air like come on
he did all that for the first ever dc
shoes skateboard video
and he wasn't satisfied with it so they
had to
re-release a new edition of the video
for danny's bonus part
where he went ape [__] on the mega ramp
with a grind bar
he went nuts on that second part
[Music]
then next thing you know they make
danny's big huge new mega ramp an actual
event at the x games
and like i think is the first year they
had it there danny's on the mega ramp
while i'm getting dragged out of the
staples center
there's no footage of that happening but
i was right there
getting his mega ramp into the x games
wasn't enough for danny
he wanted to build a whole bigger mega
ramp in china
and do a backside 360 air over the great
wall of china
which he did with a broken ankle
[Music]
he jumped out of a helicopter with a
dislocated shoulder one time
and then when he did the x games in 2008
when he hung up on the thing
boom took the most brutal slam ever
[Music]
[Applause]
and then got back up and [__] did it
again
i mean come on
the story of danny way and the mega ramp
of course with my involvement
is just so intense but now there's a
whole new generation of mega ramp
skaters
and one of them is my bro elliot sloane
who's got a mega ramp in his backyard
and all the crap elliot's up to is just
bananas
the no handed 540 he just did the front
foot impossible i mean dude it's
endless with the guy so elliot hits me
up he says yo
dude you want to do that big brother
cover you did the human field goal
and i'm thinking man i don't know dude
maybe i'll do a handstand
on the skateboard you can go through the
human field goal
so i show up at elliot's house now i
like to consider
myself a pretty gnarly guy but i'm gonna
level with you that human field goal
business was straight
creepy
i'm nervous man and i was so glad that
we got it done
safely but then the next day elliot hits
me up and says
our main camera we were filming with had
a corrupted card
so we lost the footage do you think we
could do it
again and i'm like oh okay
i show up and i'm dreading it so bad but
who's there at elliot's house but danny
way
and i wasn't going to let down my hero
so i get on that board
and we made it happen this time dude
he's even closer to my balls couldn't
have been
six inches that his board flew past my
balls i'm stevo
that's elliot sloan and this is the
human
field goal
[Music]
[Applause]
the look on his face he's like whoa it
was crazy
and i wasn't just gonna settle with that
i decided i needed to actually
skate the mega ramp of course i did that
on the flat bottom
[Music]
but the whole point of this video is
that danny way is a legend
and he's my guest on stevo's wild ride
this week we get into the extent of his
injuries we need to click through and
watch that right now
and while you're watching that ah
i need to be drawing dicks because you
guys keep buying all these books
and i gotta keep signing them